if you want to be good at something
you've got to do it every day I wake up
in the morning I splash water on my face
I brush my teeth and I immediately walk
over and I get into a cold plunge I'm
going to tell you my routine I'm going
to tell you how you could do what I do
for free so I begin every morning with a
deep meditation the form of Zen
meditation now for 12 years it's 45
minutes of sitting on pillows and
emptying your mind completely that's how
I start every single day my morning
routine I wake up I have an ice bath I
eat a delicious nutrient dense meal and
then I work out I pay myself first I
invest in me before I even step my foot
out the door